[Music]
to get healthy plants a serial farmer
must protect his plants from pests and
disease especially the leaves so that
there can for to synthesize at the
maximum rate not only can these pests
and disease destroyed the crops but they
can also contaminate the crops and
harvested produce making them unsuitable
or even dangerous for human consumption
whilst poppies may look picturesque
among yellow rose seed red flowers their
seed is very similar to oil seed rape
seed so cannot be separated during
harvest meaning when crushed for their
oil poppy seeds will also be crushed
contaminating the oil with poppy oil not
what you expect to buy in a bottle oil
bottle of own seed rare pile farmers
protect their crops using an integrated
approach which involves a combination of
methods crop rotation cultivations
and chemicals crop rotation a farmer
will rotate or change the crop seed
growers in a field each year he will aim
to grow different types of crops each
year or every few years crops like
cereals potatoes oil seed rape and peas
are not attacked by the same pests and
diseases so by rotating their crops
farmers avoid the build-up of pests and
disease in the soil and hedges around
the field which would then attack the
crops in the field
a father they also try to reduce pests
by carrying out cultivations that will
reduce the pest
if these methods don't control the pests
or disease then farmers will have to use
chemical sprays the chemical sprays are
applied using crops prayers that are
controlled by a computer in the tractor
cab and linked to GPS and sat-nav this
means that the chemical can be applied
with precision just where the disease
pests are we DS this saves on the amount
of chemical needed but also means that
only infected areas are sprayed the use
of chemicals on food crops is also
subject to tight regulations farmers
have to pass a test before they are
allowed to do this job farm assurance
schemes such as the red tractor
assurance cream also set out lots of
safety and environmental rules farmers
will speak before they can sell their
cereals for food